FRANK: Get the flyer.
MIKE: Give the double honk.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
FRANK: [honks horn]
MIKE: I'm usually driving.
I don't get the flyer.
FRANK: I know, well...
MIKE: Hello!
FRANK: That must be
him in there.
I see him.
MIKE: Yeah.
Hey, buddy, what's up?
JAY: Hey, not too much.
What are you guys up to?
MIKE: Oh, nothing, just, uh...
FRANK: Freezing!
MIKE: ...come to check you out.
I'm Mike.
JAY: Hi, Mike; Jay.
MIKE: This is Frankie.
FRANK: Frank, nice to meet you.
JAY: Hey, Frank.
MIKE: Hey, what are you doing,
some inventory or something?
JAY: Well, just
checking things out.
MIKE: Alright, here's
some more paperwork for ya.
JAY: Family business,
we were fuel distributors
where we'd haul fuel
to individuals, farmers.
The collection came
remnants from the business.
JAY: Let's go
in the building here.
This building my dad built, oh,
35 years ago for our business.
FRANK: Wow.
MIKE: Dang.
FRANK: Oh, Mike...
JAY: Kind of got stuffed full.
MIKE: Wow.
FRANK: This is obviously
where his dad kept
all of his prized possessions.
It's like a museum in here.
FRANK: Okay, Jay, you know,
this is what I call
a popsicle sign.
JAY: Um-hm.
FRANK: It's Mobiloil,
it's got the gargoyle on it.
It has the original base.
And when I look at
the sign here...
JAY: Um-hm.
FRANK: ...it's been touched up.
The retail on it would be around
1,200 in the condition it is.
JAY: Um-hm.
FRANK: I'd be into it for 875.
JAY: Tell you what.
1,000 bucks
and you take it.
FRANK: 950.
Get me somewhere else.
JAY: 1,050.
FRANK: I'll do it for 1,000.
[laughs] 1,000 sounds
better than 1,050.
JAY: My dad didn't
throw anything away,
and that's because he was
a Depression-era baby.
And everything was saved.
MIKE: So, Linco, this was
actually Ohio Oil Company.
And they bought
another oil company
named Lincoln Oil Company,
and they--
but they marketed
their products as Linco.
This is a rare sign.
This is the money
shot right here.
I'd do...
1,600 on it.
JAY: Go 18.
MIKE: 1,750.
JAY: C'mon, 18.
It's 50 bucks.
♪
MIKE: Here's the deal.
All of this stuff
is really hard to find.
We very much appreciate
you letting us look at it
and buy a few pieces.
'Cause we understand
the importance of it.
JAY: Glad it can get out,
from inside this building,
just sitting in here collecting
dust, and nobody's seeing it.
MIKE: Jay's dad was such
a passionate collector.
Everything that Jay's
father drug home
now has a second life.
MIKE: Hey...
Come to Nashville,
I'll buy you a beer.
JAY: Thanks for coming by.
MIKE: Alright, buddy.
Yeah, thank you so much.
FRANK: Yeah.
JAY: Thanks, Frank.
Nice to meet you guys.
MIKE: We appreciate you.
FRANK: Nice to meet ya, partner.
MIKE: Alright.
FRANK: Take care now.
MIKE: Stay warm!
FRANK: Y'all be good now.
[honks horn]
MIKE: See ya, Jay!
JAY: See you, guys!